but we are going to be singing a happy
tune this weekend with a beautiful
weather coming our way welcome to april
gorgeous blue skies out there sun is out
we've got a mix of some 60s but mostly
50s around the valley this morning still
60 in henderson green valley the strip
at 63. i think all the stars coming in
for the grammys are going to love the
vegas weather they'll be doing those
dayside pools you know they will at the
big hotels this weekend 81 degrees today
that's up a few degrees from yesterday
as we finished march in the upper 70s
normal high for april 1st is mid 70s
we're going to be a little bit above
that sunrise was 6 27 and sunset at 703.
see that 92 for the record record
starting off in april in the 90s and i
think we might get real close to that
next week so we've uh really between two
systems right now the one that brought
us all the high clouds for the last
couple of days and another one well off
the coast i think we'll get a little
breeze from that that next one offshore
by late tomorrow and then more clouds
with it on sunday but today lots of good
sunshine mount charleston a beautiful
day in the mid 50s to upper 50s tomorrow
and we've got some northerly breezes
this morning that will turn more to the
south and light for the afternoon 81
slides up to the mid 80s for saturday
now that second system will bring
stronger winds across the colorado river
valley and clouds for all of us by
sunday but boy next week look how we
warm up even into the low 90's by
tuesday but again only lasts for a day
we'll spend most of our first week of
april in the 80s